[Music]
let's go to
jack in charlotte north carolina jack is
back
what's up jack how we doing
oh there you are run through the wall
like the kool-aid hello hey there you
are what's up man
am i on i was just saying uh your your
promo for that book maybe you want to
run through a wall so i appreciate that
hey listen don't do that just buy it
don't run through anything we need you
just kidding good for you man i'm
excited i'm excited i'm excited how are
you man
i'm doing all right i've been uh
fighting a bit of a cold so i'm sorry if
my voice isn't exactly that pleasant
it's all good and sure it's a cold as
they call it way to go sure jack so
what's up dude
um so i just have a question about my
mom i don't know exactly how to go about
encouraging her to get away from an
abusive relationship she's in
with my stepdad
so i'll just give some background she's
been married to him for five years now
um back then i was in high school i
would stay weekends with her
and he would just he would shout he'd
curse in her face call her names
threaten her physically
it was bad enough for me that i mean i
basically hid from her i stopped doing
our visitation
and we really had
after that no contact for a year and a
half or so
he ended up in jail and she filed for
divorce for a bit um this your
biological dad or a stepdad
this is my stepdad okay all right
where's your biological dad
my biological dad is still in town
and so i ended up after i stopped seeing
my mom for that period of time
um i pretty much spent all of my time
with my biological dad who's great by
the way awesome okay cool all right so
then he your stepdad goes to jail he
says scumbag
and
then what
um so she and i started to
rebuild our relationship over the next
after the months that followed
um and while he was in prison he
basically sweet talked her found jesus
in jail and she let him back in
after
six or seven months of prison he came
back
so he was he had kind of turned it
around a little bit
but in the meantime i left for college
and my little sister has started to that
was about three or so years ago and over
that time my little sister started to
tell me hey he's kind of picking up on
his old patterns you know
so some of the things that he
he's called my mom he's saying again
he's shouting at him he's scaring them
um what really scared me the most and
the reason i i guess i called you in the
first place uh was one night she uh
she called me and she told me
hey we had to basically hide in our own
home from this guy
um we had to lock the door because he
was shouting name-calling going on one
of his uh things again
um and so i was like well you said hold
on when you said go on one of his things
and i don't mean to interrupt you this
is important
going on one of his things again what
does that mean like be very specific
what does that mean
um so he'll get going
is he smashing things is he hitting
people is he
getting in people's faces throwing
things abusing like what's he do what
does that mean
uh it's slamming objects it's shouting
it's cursing calling people
um i guess cursing um
i don't know about the words i can use
on the show i guess um
but basically he he called my mom and my
little sister a piece of [ __ ] yeah
and i
when she told me that he was on this
rant that he was hitting things that he
was yelling
and i said hey maybe i should come back
and talk to y'all about this she was
like well i kind of wish i hadn't told
you now because i i think mom's gonna be
mad at me for telling you oh god dude
yeah that's a classic
that's a classic statement of somebody
who's in an abusive situation
that feels responsible to make sure
mom's okay
because dad's
insane
oh man
so what are you gonna do
um i don't know i just i want to have
this conversation with her
i do remember the last time we had a
talk like this that proceeded you know
the 18 or so month that we really didn't
talk to each other much
i don't want to damage our relationship
and i
feel like she knows she has to know how
old are you troubling
i am 21. okay i need you to
like i want you to tighten your fists
both of them as tight as they'll go okay
okay and i want you to hold your breath
take a deep as breath as you possibly
can and hold it
one
two and then let it all out and then
relax your hands
okay
i want you to hear me directly
anything that happens from this point
forward
is not gonna be on you
it will be because you
there's a huge difference
because you're gonna act
a beautiful little girl is gonna be safe
because you're going to act maybe but
probably not
your mom will
understand she's worth more than yet
another abusive relationship
your mom and your relationship did not
go sideways because you spoke up your
mom and your relationship went sideways
because she chose an abusive man over
you
you hear me say that
yes sir and i don't like talking about
somebody's mom but i'm being direct and
honest with you right
yes and that sucks and it hurts and it
shouldn't be that way
and then when he went to jail she came
around and realized what am i doing
and i know your mom's got her own story
and so i'm not gonna sit here and just
bash her mom
but that's the reality of what happened
she chose him
that was not your fault
and you cannot spend the rest of your
life trying to
build a bridge back towards your mom
because you're not the one that broke
the original bridge she is
okay
right
and that sucks
that's hard
and
you've got to let your mom know i will
call cps i'll call the police i will
call whoever my sister will not be in
this situation period
how old is this girl
she's 16.
brother she doesn't deserve that and you
know it right
yeah and that's why you're calling me
and is this your
did you cause any of this not a second
of it but now it's in your lap as a 21
year old
and your mom knows
is that fair
yeah
man
my heart's broken for you brother
for your sister for your mom for the
whole situation
so let's practice this what's it look
like
to be honest what's it look like you set
up and said tell your mom hey we need to
meet for breakfast we need to have
coffee i'm coming into town will she
meet with you
oh absolutely okay
so
i'm gonna tell you something that i tell
folks when like i worked with a group of
executives the other day um on
firing how to how to let somebody go
with dignity
and one of the things that often happens
when people are going to fire somebody
is it gets it's it's hard to take
somebody's livelihood away unless you're
a sociopath right firing somebody always
sucks i've had to do it a bunch it's not
fun
and
you end up talking too much and you're
like well you know thinking about and
then and and him all around and it
tortures people
the most gifted
um
fire i've ever had i don't know that's
right i call that
um was a guy that taught me how to do it
the right way which is you walk in and
you sit down and say
the decision has been made you will no
longer be working here period or
i am terminating your employment here
effective immediately
this decision has been made and it is
final
that from that point forward nobody's
listening to you right so they have gone
full limbic they're not listening to you
they're in defense mode what i do what
happened i'm scared all that
what you have to do is sit down with
your mom and have the very similar
conversation
i love you and so i'm going to be direct
i've been talking to my sister and she's
in the same mess that i was in and i
will not stand for my sister to be in
this mess
period
you have 20 days or two weeks or one
week to get her out of there
or i'm going to call every official i
know tell my story tell her story and
then i'm gonna it's gonna you're gonna
deal with the authorities
i don't see another way around it do you
i don't um
are you out of college can she move in
with you i mean i guess that's another
option
no i'm still in college she couldn't
move in with me and the thing is she she
lived alone obviously while he was uh
out in jail no no i'm not talking about
your mom talking about your little
sister oh no she can't move in with me
why not um you said that all like nah
bro i got bearded
well no no i i guess the more practical
option would be she would go and live
with my dad okay okay
and and i see what you're saying now
about it not being
my fault it being because of me i i my
thought is like i don't want to be the
guy who takes her away from my mom that
would break my heart as much as i
you okay so let me tell you this i love
her you will be the guy that saves her
from your mom
and she needs an adult in her life to
save her right now
because she's a child
she's 16 she's probably beautiful she's
probably mature growing up in that crap
she's probably real mature but she's a
child
and she needs some adult in her life to
care and love about her have you sat
down and told your dad about this
uh he knows about it he knows about it
because she will talk to him about it
um
i haven't i guess he probably doesn't
know the full extent of it okay um as as
much as my sister has told me and
obviously like i said backtrack and be
like oh maybe i shouldn't have told you
that well she's hiding i hadn't thought
about that i may have screwed that up i
i may call your dad and say here's the
deal i'm gonna sit down have a hard
conversation with mom
sister's in an abusive situation with
step dad with that piece of crap and um
she needs a place to go it's got to be
your house dad and i'm going to sit down
and tell mom that she's got a week to
make this the whole thing happen or i'm
going to call the police and whoever and
let your dad know
i'm about to step in here and be the
adult because no one seems to want to
and hopefully he will say oh my god this
is my daughter
i'll get involved he might not
that's my hope
um i know for a fact he will okay then
good and here's a hard thing this is
another hard conversation that you have
to have
and i'd have it with your sister and
it's going to feel hard now
but it will be less hard one year down
the road three years down the road and
10 years down the road okay just trust
me on this you're gonna have to let her
know you told me some things and i said
i wouldn't tell anybody but i have to
and i'm sorry i'm gonna violate your
trust
but i can't allow you to be in an
abusive household anymore you're my baby
sister i love you too much and she may
get mad and say i can never trust you
again i'm never going to tell you
anything and you will be saving her life
okay
okay you will not be taking her from her
mom you will be saving her from her mom
you'll be taking her from a family
you'll be saving her
what a gift that she's got you as an
older brother
and i don't know how you your dad must
be amazing
the fact that you've been able to come
out of this thing with character and
strength and resilience is a testament
to you and those who love you
not to the mess and crap you came up man
i'm proud of you
proud of you this is grown-up stuff
right
sure is it's hard
have you seen somebody yet
i have not
you have to you trust me you got to
absolutely i see it um i know as you
would say it's a whole other call but
i've seen it crop up in my own
relationships that's right
this is what you know
you're a child of divorce you're a child
of separation you're a child of abuse
you're a child of parent abandonment and
neglect
when it comes to the aces score the
adverse childhood experiences you can
google that just google aces score and
take that test it's about 10 questions
my guess is
you're at a four okay
you know what that means right
yes you're at an elevated risk for all
sorts of stuff unless you deal with it
man because your body's dealing with it
every minute of every day
and you're gonna replay the scripts that
were rolled out in front of you you're
gonna replay these stories that you got
from your original parents from your
step you're gonna you're gonna replay
that stuff over and over and over and it
may not look exactly the same
but man i can already hear you wanna
protect your mom you wanna protect
because that's what you had to do
between her and that idiot
you want to love your dad talk about how
great he is
he might be right you want to
be the guy who makes sure everybody's
okay dude that's an exhausting
job
not your job that's your mom and dad's
job brother
and i hate they didn't do that for you
so do i have your word you're gonna make
a call you talk to your old man soon
today tomorrow
i will do it today okay i'm proud of you
and then you're gonna talk to your
sister
i will okay and your dad may try to talk
you out of it let him know
i'm grown up now grown-up jack i'm 21
year old jack
i can buy beer and guns and i can
protect my sister not necessarily in
that order with those tools right it's a
grown-up conversation it's different
than y'all have ever had before probably
right
absolutely yes hey i'm proud of you
call me let me know how that
conversation goes or write me a note and
let me know how that conversation goes
okay it's gonna be messy it's gonna be
hard you're gonna feel isolated you can
feel alone i want you to call somebody
make sure you've got some people in your
corner too
cool
thank you dr d i appreciate it i'm super
proud of you my brother super proud of
you man